èg alors il y a un système fabus je sais
pas c'est point d'interrogation Laurent
fabus est-il un rénovateur en tout cas
en tant que oui enant que président
alors vous avez souhaité alléger
certaines procédures et faire en sorte
que le que le Parlement joue le plus
possible son son rôle d'intermédiaire
entre le citoyen et le gouvernement
alors un coup d'œil sur ce que l'on
pourrait donc appeler le système fabus
vu par Roland
si Laurent Fabius l'avait annoncé DS il
faudrait plus que quelques roulements de
tambour pour réveiller le Palais Bourbon
et très vite le nouveau président de
l'Assemblée nationale passait à l'action
l'absentéisme chronique dans l'hémicycle
commençaitil est vrai à faire un peu
désordre premier exemple spectaculaire
les questions cribles du jeudi à
l'inverse des traditionnelles questions
orales les ministres se présentent ici
sans connaître à l'avance les
interrogations des députés Laurent
Fabius en espéré des échanges au tacac
fait personne ne jouera vraiment le jeu
et le crible ne créera que très rarement
l'événement malgré sa retransmission en
direct par une chaîne
privée autre initiative très médiatique
l'ouverture aux caméras de télévision
des auditions en commission des
ministres peut-être pour démontrer que
lorsque l'hémicycle est vide les députés
travaillent autre part à la préparation
des
lois et puis Laurent Fabius c'est aussi
l'ouverture ouverture aux personnalités
étrangères comme les
ou tout simplement l'ouverture au public
les visites de l'édifice sont rétablies
et surtout le Palais Bourbon se met à
l'heure du bicentenaire avec une
exposition qui a attiré plus de 155000
personnes à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée
le kiosque a été créé carte postale
figurine documents livres les curieux
peuvent tout s'y procurer c'est la
boutique souvenir du
Parlement résultat du dépoussiérage des
procédures à l'ouverture vers le public
Laurent Fabius n'a pas ménagé ses
efforts pour améliorer l'image du
Parlement pourtant beaucoup reste à
faire plus facile de changer l'Assemblée
en façade que de la transformer en
profondeur